[Music]
you gonna come with me if you want and
why would I do that
boys lots and lots of Mortal boys to
torment maybe you'll find the meaning of
life at Baxter high oh you had me at
boys to torment you are such a scene
stealer I've seen the whole first season
prudence is incredible what was it like
for you to step into this character and
just turn on your inner witch but it's
been very empowering honestly because in
my day to day life
I'm very bubbly I'm very smiley I'm a
really different person than prudence to
really get to know prudence and to learn
her strength to learn her confidence in
her unwillingness to back down she's
really like an OBS kind of chick it's
been extremely like a learning
experience as far as my own womanhood
and gaining some
some dog isn't that what you are half
witch ha mortal stay with your own kind
I love the friendship that evolves
between prudence and Sabrina can you
talk a little bit about that an
evolution of their friendship yeah I
think to start of course it thinks
prudence is grudge against sabrina is
simply that she is half mortal and the
prudence really I think carries the
history of which is deep in her heart
the back that mortals have put so much
discrimination against witches
throughout centuries they don't even
know the glorious truth what you are I
think throughout this season as prudence
gets to know Sabrina a little more she
because she learns to respect her
resilience and her unwillingness to back
down and the fact that she's gonna stand
up for what she believes in and there's
like it no you can't really bite that
you have to respect that so it's it's
nice to see the way that guru dance is
like okay you know this kid's got grit I
can get with that seat and I'll tear you
to pieces and say the feast day if there
were to be a Sabrina Riverdale crossover
who would you like to see prudence share
a scene with I would love to see
prudence share of scene with Jughead or
even Veronica I feel like me and
Veronica like prudence and Veronica's
could do some really like kick-ass stuff
like I think that that would be dope mr.
pleasure lastly what can you tease about
what's coming next to prudence when we
last saw her in season 1 she's walking
down the hallway breena's got her ice
white hair you get a little you get to
dig a little bit deeper into Prudence's
story and learning where some of that
rage comes from you promise me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]